and my goal is to be not just the
libertarian presidential candidate 2012
but the ross perot of 2012 hi I'm Matt
Welch editor-in-chief of Reason magazine
and I'm pleased to be joined by 2008
vice presidential nominee for the
Libertarian Party Wayne Allyn root met
how are you on who was also the author
of a new book that's coming out in
stores near you any second now called
the conscience of a libertarian got to
give the subtitle got to give it
powering the citizen revolution with God
Guns gambling at tax cuts no way I was
going to remember I save it was sale
thank you first let's start about
talking about 2008 there are a lot of
libertarians both small l capital l who
were expecting more from a high-profile
candidate like bob barr and in the year
of Ron Paul then what was then the
results that you received are you do you
feel a sense of disappointment about
that or do you think it was a victory
and what do you what do you see sort of
the dynamics that when you know I feel
tremendously disappointed at the results
of 2008 I think it was a dud of a
campaign I think there were a thousand
factors that went into it one of them
was that Bob just didn't get the media
that he should have gotten and I don't
know Bob's to blame or the national
media didn't care because you had Obama
against mccain it was such a classic
matchup and the whole world was talking
about obama trying to stop obama on the
conservative side and the whole world on
the liberal side had to get rid of
george w bush and so all of it led to a
dud of a campaign but the one good thing
that i think and i hope came out of it
without without too much ego here the
reality is i had over a thousand media
interviews and no libertarian vice
presidential candidate has ever gotten
off the map with I think morning in
interviews let alone major national fox
news interviews so for me it was all a
preparation for 2012 and my goal is to
be not just the libertarian presidential
candidate 2012 but the ross perot of
2012 i expect to make a real difference
in the next election and as your book
amply shows in 2016 and 2020 you have a
whole time lining will and we'll get
into that i don't think it's possible to
win in 2012 only four years after
getting on the National map and and
really for the average person the first
time i'll be on the National map will be
2012 I think my plan for the beginning
is
great recognition 2008 I did that get a
VP nomination major third party then
become the nominee in 2012 then have a
credible chance to win a 2016 and
actually put the ball over the goal line
in 2016 or 2020 that's the plan your
previous book was called millionaire not
libertarian republican you are a semi
late arrival to the Libertarian Party
and we're living at a time where a lot
of Republicans who had been for many
good reasons dissatisfied with george w
bush are waking up in obama's world of
bailouts and heavy government spending
and some people think it's kind of a
fertile time for the GOP to rediscover
some libertarian roots so why not make
it work within the Republican Party why
that on libertarian party right well I
think it's a fertile time for
conservatives and libertarians to make
it work not necessarily the label GOP or
republican I think the Republican Party
is an embarrassment I think it's a
dinosaur I don't know if it's coming
back I'm not certain that it is coming
back talk a little bit about the online
gaming component of this you makes
pretty bold claims you've you are or
have been an oddsmaker and it made a
good living doing that that there's a
nation of online gamblers out here who
are mad as hell and not going to take it
anymore talk a little bit about what how
the policy has been and how awful it has
been and how that's a potential
constituency well it's pretty simple
Matt you know if I can't gamble with my
own money in my own house on my own
computer that shows you how bad
government is and how controlling
government is it's a small issue let's
face it the Iraq war the war in
Afghanistan you know foreign aid being
wasted around the world and the bailouts
the entitlements and the handouts and
everything you could name is bigger than
a silly issue like poker but i think
it's not a silly issue and I think it's
not a small issue I think it's a big
issue first of all there's 20 million
online poker players somewhere in that
neighborhood the numbers range from 10
to 12 million on poker alone to 20
million when you throw in sports
gambling and online lotteries and
everything else that's a lot of people
when you see polls detailed polls about
gambling it's the highest number of any
issue I've ever seen eighty-six percent
of all americans support gambling and
think state government should be free to
decide whether gambling is legal or not
in their state what is you're looking
looking at Obama and looking out with
the direction of things in the akan
me how bad can it get what name would
you put on where we might go in terms of
your sort of worst fears and then what
are your sources of hope going forward
well I mean economic Armageddon would be
the way I would describe where we're
headed you know the idea that you know I
like to break it down to a person give a
person had a house worth a hundred
thousand dollars and a mortgage of eight
million dollars and then they owed
another eight million to other people so
a total of sixteen million of debt and a
total of a hundred thousand value in an
income of 50,000 a year and that person
walked up to you and said the way I'm
going to get out of this mess matt is
I'm going to borrow another 30 million
from a bank you'd look at him and say
you're a [ __ ] you're an idiot you're a
complete fool and you're headed for
disaster Obama has done that he's
tripled down on Daddy's quadruple down
on debt he's tripled down on deficit
he's tripled down and anything you could
name and the first economic stimulus
package which was almost a trillion
dollars eight hundred billion to be
exact complete waste and did nothing for
the economy except burden future
generations with debt so I think we're
staring at an apocalypse now a disaster
and Armageddon whatever word you want to
use and my whole book which which you
got an advance copy so you've read it
the whole thing is really using
California as the model for America vs
nevada my adopted home state as the
model for America California is the
canary in the coal mine what's happening
there now bankruptcy Jack deficit Louis
bond ratings in the country they're just
completely in solvent and what and iou's
don't forget iou's what's happening
there is going to happen to the whole
country in a rolling disaster over the
next couple of years and I'm not alone
in this you've got the Peter shifts the
world who I've studied and read all
their books in the last just the last
few months I've come to Peter and read
his books and said holy crap this guy
got it right in the first place he was
the one who got it right at what bothers
me is when he goes on TV he was the one
who was embarrassed they all said you're
an idiot you don't know what you're
saying he was right about everything now
that he's right guess what they say oh
you're too negative we don't want to
talk to you anymore they still won't
give credit where credit's due Ron Paul
was right Peter Schiff was right many
people like that were right and nobody
gives us libertarians credit for being
right the ones who sought coming should
be the ones they come to
how do we get out of this mess now
instead they're doubling down with the
group that got us in this nightmare in
the first place well we could talk all
day with Wayne Allyn root but we don't
have enough time but thank you very much
for text by push it or recent TV I'm
Matt Welch